there is so much of knowledge available
today on instantly bold dishes are not
free of risk so they should analyze the
risk very carefully being responsible is
vital to a company's long-term success
my goal post keeps on changing as we
move forward in the life during the
crisis and post crisis always there has
been and there will be exciting pursuits
first of all you have to have a
commitment and dedication and passion
for what you are doing
one day I realize that I am getting
addicted to God we could be born with
the baldness not with the poorness and
this is not only tragic but not
acceptable if you have to grow we have
to do something differently than what
everyone else has been doing he's an
Indian steel magnate based in the United
Kingdom he's the chairman and CEO of the
world's largest steelmaking company as
of December 2015 he was listed by Forbes
to have a net worth of 9.5 billion
dollars he's Laxmi natal and here is top
10 rules for success there is so much of
knowledge available today one instantly
and knowledge is the key if you have the
knowledge if you have ambition if you
are determined if you are focused if you
are committed use this knowledge to grow
everyone can do it and this is what I
would like to say to all young men in
India
I see bold decisions have to be very
transformative and it has to succeed and
bold decisions are not easy to take so
this young people have to have a lot of
experience they have to have
determination they have to have a
commitment and they have to think
through those issues very carefully bold
decisions are not free of risk so they
should analyze the risk very carefully
but definitely bold decisions could be a
very transformative decision
in the business what they are I would
increase young people to continue to
analyze their situation and take bold
diseases because otherwise you cannot
make a step change in your career being
responsible is vital to a company's
long-term success I have always believed
this because being responsible not only
has benefits for society it has clear
benefits for the business let me give
two examples first our success in
reducing our own co2 emissions has cost
benefits secondly in developing new and
innovative products to help our
customers improve their environmental
performance and we maintain our market
leading position did you ever foresee
the kind of success you've had when
you're in Indonesia and things where
that's did you ever foresee it I never
expected that we would reach here and
I'm not a person who sets very high goal
you don't set high goals my goalpost
keeps on changing as we move forward in
the life then you're not very
disappointed if you don't succeed it's
always been one step forward always make
a small step forward and you become
stronger and to gain confidence then you
change your goal posts so it gives you
more pleasure than setting up a very
high goal and you don't reach them I
don't think we ever talked I have over
dad more than a year ahead is that right
last couple of years we have been
thinking more five year strategy oh yeah
I'm talking of those days yeah in the
beginning we were looking very
short-term you this challenging time
gives us a lot of experience there too
kind of situation one what are the bold
decisions we could have taken during the
crisis a lot of companies took the
opportunity of taking bold decisions
during the crisis and reshape their
business model for the
future they have stripped of some of the
sets they have reduced their cost they
have flexible eyes their fixed cost and
expenses they they have they've started
spending a lot of money on innovation
and for the future
they've started diversifying to emerging
markets so there has been lot of bold
distance taken during the crisis and
post crisis I see that companies need to
take bold decisions to design their
business model for next 20 years looking
at the growth areas looking at their
port cities so I believe that during the
crisis and post crisis always there has
been and there will be exciting purchase
story goes back to when I was 16 years
old like past my Hindi medium school in
Kolkata and then applied for admission
in Sanjiv years since I came from Hindi
middle school father juris at the time
was a principal felt that I would not be
able to fit in in an english-medium
college though I was top in my class in
school I got admission in other other
colleges but I really wanted to study in
Sanjay views so I kept on knocking his
door every day and to finally give it up
and I promised him that I'll be a good
student which I did and and how did this
experience sort of shape shape you as a
business person I mean you're breaking
down doors breaking ceilings is that
something that you learned at sensei
vias it was a challenge for me to prove
other juries wrong that coming from
individual school cannot do well in an
english-medium College and that
challenge really gave me a lot of
learnings I determined myself that I
would prove him wrong and I really
dedicated myself committed to myself
that I have to accept this challenge and
continue to work hard
focus on the studies and this is a great
learning in the business life that first
of all you have to have a commitment
dedication and passion for what you are
doing as I said everyone works hard but
something needs to differentiate
yourself with some others is
focus dedicate commit and continue a
card I don't like to get addicted to
anyone hobby
okay for example I started playing golf
I liked it I liked it a lot every day in
the morning I would go and practice one
day I realize that I am getting addicted
to God so one day in the morning I was
driving to golf course and suddenly I
realized that this is not right turn
around so I turned back the car and so
then I never played again so you don't
have any addictions
I don't like addiction I think it could
distract me from my focus they are not
born with the boldness
we could be born with the baldness not
with the poorness it is not that
something you learn only from education
education is only one enabler but you
have to have experience you have to have
experience of success which means you
gain some confidence and then you have
to have your small goals small goals set
up in your life and if you succeed and
if you think that you are more confident
than before you want to take bold
decisions in the future but I will
always be concerned about health and
safety until we reached a place of zero
accidents and zero fatalities there were
a number of fatalities again in 2012 and
this is not only tragic but not
acceptable we have to remain dedicated
to addressing this problem
I want our senior leaders to lead by
example that's why I have asked my
colleagues on GMB and MMC to spend more
time on the shop floor and promote
increased training and awareness for
both our employees and our contractors
this is how we will drive further
improvement I was in Tokyo with one of
the businessmen from
and when I was talking to him I realized
that acquisition is a way to grow I
realize that life is very short and if
you have to really do something you have
to do very quickly if you have to grow
we have to do something differently than
what everyone else has been doing so I
started thinking that if I start
building a steel plant it would take
years and how many steel plants how many
companies you can build and if I have to
succeed in my life I have to find a
formula which is different and which
keeps me ahead of my competition and my
clicks that's how I thought that we
should acquire companies merge
consolidate them reduce their cost make
them very efficient and it became like a
turn around became a science I would say
that yeah it sort of there's science or
art it is a mix of science and art
because every company has a different
issue it's not that there is a formula
which you apply eye on everyone yeah it
is not as to all its quick water here
but the pattern you establish this
pattern and applied it in different
countries different markets yes and that
was the genesis of your empire yes thank
you so much for watching we made this
video because John Simon asked us to now
if you have a famous entrepreneur you'd
like a video made of leave a comment
below I'd also love to know which of the
top 10 rules meant the most to you will
have the biggest impact on you today
leaving the comments will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon